denise felt as we have been following
this breaking news just outside of town
four people are confirmed dead after a
six-car crash on i-15 this is all
happening near sloan just a few miles
south of saint rose parkway victoria
saha has been in that area throughout
the night joins us now live with what
police say happened there victoria
denise this fiery crash has closed down
the southbound traffic here for the last
five hours you can see behind me drivers
are having to get off an exit 25 but the
crash happened on exit 20.
nevada state police say the woman
driving this red cadillac was going the
wrong way on i-15 southbound between
sloan and jean when she crashed head on
with this toyota pickup truck causing it
to go up in flames all three people
inside that truck died along with the
woman in that red cadillac state police
say because of evidence found on scene
they suspect the wrong way driver was
under the influence of alcohol trooper
ashley wellman gave us an update just
after examining the scene for herself
it's horrific it's a tragedy
and
it was probably all preventable and it's
just it's so sad police say three other
cars were involved in the crash
including a volvo a kia and a semi truck
that was trying to swerve away from the
crash scene the drivers of the volvo and
kia were taken to the hospital and are
expected to be okay
as of right now we do know six cars in
total were involved but trooper wellman
says that could change if you are
planning on using this route just
remember it will be closed until the
early morning hours reporting near i-15
and sloan victoria saha live local now